puberty blockers became available
as sort of standardized practice at
these younger ages from 2014.
although some of the clinicians didn't
understand perhaps why you might refer
even after six sessions which was the
kind of the assessment model they didn't
they weren't overly concerned because
in their eyes at that time what they
were constantly being told and there was
nothing to suggest to the country was
that what the puberty blockers did was
they provided time to think
and there were no long-term effects
um and they were completely reversible
and actually what so many of those young
people needed was time to think they
were very very distressed and the
rationale of the blocker makes perfect
sense
that you're just you've got this
mismatch between your biological sex and
the gender identity that you
you know that you perceive
you stop your body going through the
puberty of your biological sex and then
you can hopefully take away some of that
distress and then think about things
now
it was only really when so so in those
years 2015 ish
lots of clinicians told me that
pretty much any young person that wanted
the blocker
could have it during quite a quick
assessment and actually as long as they
met the criteria for gender dysphoria
which pretty much all of them did
because they're silly and most teenagers
would meet them
they would be referred for puberty
blockers what were the criteria for
gender dysphoria that you say were Silly
well
they think I mean that I mean one area
this is a rare moment of agreement from
both those who are very pro-medical
intervention and those who are very
against is that that you know they're
steeped in gender stereotypes so it'd be
things like
playing with toys that are typically
associated with the opposite sex having
friends that are mostly of the opposite
sex
um wanting to be
the opposite you know they're just
so if I were a girl who was a bit of a
tomboy yeah and I felt some sort of
distress puberty blockers off you go
well yeah you have to have the distress
and it has to be for more than six
months but six months is is not a huge
amount of time no it's not a huge amount
of time
um and actually
the the the
the small amount of data that we do have
kind of bears out that in those years of
2014 15 16.
a lot of people well proportionally lots
of people were referred like this data
that I mentioned before that
they didn't release because apparently
no one has it but there's a graph it's
the only graph in the book and it
actually shows that you know of those
who were referred in adolescence the
majority went on to be referred for
puberty blockers and the peak is at
about 14 and I turned into absolute Uber
geek and I actually blew this thing up
and I'm measuring it and I'm like oh one
millimeter is this and so I do actually
get their numbers and it's about 70 of
14 year olds during this particular time
period
and now you get an average of
a minority 40 because
the the really young ones obviously
aren't eligible to be referred and so
it's the classic the average the main
the mean is meaningless because it hides
what's going on in the middle
so that being the case
when was the moment that the medical
community started to go
there's something very wrong going on
here
it was really when the first bit of data
came back from this study that had begun
which challenged all the assumptions
they had about puberty blockers because
what this showed was that
of those who had
become old enough by that point every
single one of them
had gone from the puberty blocker to
cross-sex hormones
but also
that there'd been no psychological
benefit to being on the puberty blocker
and so
for Dr Anna Hutchinson
she describes learning that as her holy
[__] moment because it exploded
everything that they were doing she said
you know what are the chances of being
given time to think and all children and
young people thinking the same way she's
like that just doesn't happen it doesn't
happen in Psychology and also even if
we gave them time to that this is what
they did do there was no space to think
in the Tavistock model anyway in the
kids model because when you went on the
blocker you didn't have more talking you
had less
you got seen every three to six months
and so
and actually
these young people weren't feeling
better in some cases both
psychologically and physically they were
getting worse
and so at that point
quite a sizable number of collisions
just went
this isn't safe what we're doing
foreign